في تونس قال رئيس الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات فاروق بوعسكر ان النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات التشريعيه التي جرت
السبت سيتم الاعلان عنها بعد غدا الاثنين
كان ابو عسكر قال ان اكثر من 800000 ناخذ
ادله باصواتهم قبل اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع
بساعتين وذلك بنسبه مشاركه الثمانيه
بالمئه هذا واغلقت مراراكز الاقتراع
ابوابها بانتظاري نتائج منافسه
201858 مرشحا على المئه و 161 مقعدا في
مجلس النواب من بينهم واثنتين 122 امراه
سوف تحال محاضر الفرز على مراكز التجميع
في مقرات هيئاتنا الفرعيه
لتتم معالجتها هذه الليله ويوم غد
وسوف يتم الاعلان الرسمي عن النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات حالمه يكون مجلس
الهيئه كل المعطيات المتعلقه بجميع
المحاضر التجميع الصادر عن جميع هيئه
الفرعيه في تونس وخارج تونس وايضا كل
المعطيات المتعلقه بالمحاضر وبالتقارير
الخاصه بمراقبه الحمله سواء الصادره عن
اعوان مراقبه الحمله او عن هيئاتنا
الفرعيه او عن خلايا الرصد التابعه للهيئه
همم المتعلقه طبعا برصه الصحافه السمعيه
والبصريه والمكتوبه والالكترونيه والفضاء
المفتوح
مبدئيا همم
قد تعلن الهيئه يوم بعد يوم الغد ان شاء
الله على نتائج الاوليه بعد التثبت في كل
ذلك
طبعا الاعلان عن النتائج الاوليه يقتضي
يعني التحري في خصوص المخالفات المرتكبه
من الفائزين في شتى الدوائر
التجميع الاصوات التي ستقوم به ليله
الفرعي هو عدل الاصوات ولكن النتائج
الاوليه بما
يفترضه من تطبيق حتى لمقتديت الفصل 143
وامكانيه او كل هذا من صميم صلاحيه مجلس
الهيئه بعد التثبت من كل هذه المحاضر
والتقارير
من تونس ينضم الى مراسل العربيه وليد عبد
الله وليد اهلا بك معنا ابرز الملاحظات
على هذا اليوم الانتخابات الطويل
الملاحظات بل اهمها على الاطلاق هو نسب
المشاركه
المتدنيه في هذه الانتخابات التشريعيه
كفامه الانتخابات منذ سنه 2011 ورابع
عمليه انتخابيه تشريعيه اذا ما احتسبنا
انتخابات المجلس الوطني
التاسيس اني سبت رواحه بين 69 بالمئه
مسجله في انتخابات 2004 10 و 41 بالمئه في
سنه 2019 واكثر من 50 بالمئه في 2001 10
لكن النسبه اليوم لم تتجاوز التسعه بالمئه
التلامس العشره بالمئه على اعتبار ان ال-
همم الاحصاءات المعلنه او النسبه المعلنه
لما تاخذ بعين الاعتبار الدوائر
الانتخابيه في منطقه جورجيس وجربه التي لم
تعلن عنه ما هي الانتخابات الى حدود هذه
اللحظه حيث تجري الان عمليه فرز المحاضر
وتجميع
الصناديق نقلها للهيئات الفرعيه على ان
يتم ذلك ااه في مرحله لاحقه نقل هذه
النتائج الى الهيئه او مقر المركزي لهيئات
الانتخابات التي قد تعلن مساء يوم غد او
على اقصى تقدير كما تحدث رئيس الهيئه عن
النتائج الاوليه يوم الاثنين خاصه ان نسب
المشاركه لم تكن كبيره ابرز الملاحظات
ايضا ميسون هو الجدل الذي رافق العمليه
الانتخابيه منذ بدايتها الى حدود هذه
اللحظه ردود فعل متباينه بين من يتحدث عن
انتخابات نزيهه وشفافه لاول مره دون مال
سياسي دون تمويل عمومي دون حضور للاحزاب
السياسيه
بين ظفرين والمكان المكينات الدعائيه
الاعلاميه التي تستغل وسائل الاعلام
والمال السياسي للترويج لاحزاب سياسيه دون
برامج اس 8 هو ال همم ثلاثه الاف ناخبه
الذين توجهوا اليوم الى صناديق الاقتراع
يقولون انهم بمجهود فردي من المترشحين
للانتخابات القادمه في ردود الفعل ميسون
ايضا وهذا ما لاحظنا هناك من دعا الى
ضروره اجراء انتخابات رئاسيه السابقه
لاوانيها كحل من الحلول بعد هذه النتائج
المسجله في الانتخابات التشريعيه ولكن
هناك من يتحدث ايضا على ان هذا العزوفه عن
الذهاب الى صناديق الاقتراع هو نتيجه
للازمه السياسيه التي تمر بها البلاد
ورساله واضحه لمن هم في السلطه وايضا
للمعارضين بان السياسه لم تعد هي الشغل
الشاغله التونسيين اليوم بل للكباب على
الملفات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وليد هناك
النسبه يعني ماذا يقول المحللون الخبراء
همم هل تؤثر مثلا هذه النسبه المتدنيه بان
همم يطعن همم البعض بهذه النتيجه بانها لا
تمثل كل التونسيين مثلا
في الحقيقه ميسون هذه النسبه لا يمكن
الطعن فيها الا من قبل المترشحين
والمشاركين في الانتخابات التشريعيه بشكل
قانونيا لدى المحكمه الاداريه وهو الطعن
الوحيد الذي يمكن النظر فيه وفق القانون
الانتخابيه على ان تعلن النتائج النهائيه
بعد استفاق النظر بشكل قضائيا وقانوني من
قبل المحكمه الاداريه في الطعون المقدمه
ان وجدت بعد اعلان النتائج النهائيه هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه كل ما يحدث ماهو
الا من سوى تجاذبات سياسيه بين المساندين
للمشروع الرئيس قيس الصعيد والرافدين له
وخاصه من حركه النهضه ومن لف لفه من
الاحزاب السياسيه كانت موجوده في ساحه قبل
اجراءات الاستثنائيه في الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو عدى ذلك الكل ينتظر هنا تركيز
المؤسسه البرلمانيه الجديده التي
وتاسيسها خاصه وان هناك حديث عن دور ثانيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه لاول مره في افقي
شهر مارس من العام المقبل وبالتالي لا
حديث عن امكانيه تعون الاخرى واحترازات من
شكل اخر عدم ينص عليه القانون الانتخابي
ميسون شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات وهذه
التفاصيل وليد عبد الله مراسل العربيه كنت
مع من تونس